tiempo de nuevo para la crónica
deportiva de mediodía a quién france24
como siempre con nuestra compañera de
humanes a umar comenzamos con el
despliegue que tiene france24 en este
mes de julio porque ha comenzado ya el
mundial del atletismo en oregón y allí
tienen presencia como decías también
france24 otra vez en nuestro enviado
especial juan josé sayago será el primer
mundial que se dispute en eeuu y también
habrá en juego objetivos muy ambiciosos
por parte de atletas latinoamericanos
juan jose le damos la bienvenida le
preguntamos que podemos esperarnos de
esta jornada inaugural hola omar un
placer saludarte a toda la audiencia de
france 24 estamos en el corazón de la
universidad de oregon engine ams
espaldas ven el warfield el escenario
especial donde se va a disputar las
pruebas de atletismo desde este día
viernes hasta el próximo 25 de julio
hoy habrá
esta jornada inaugural con algunas
clasificaciones como el martillo por
ejemplo pero tendremos tres finales las
de los 20 kilómetros marcha masculino y
femenino y la del relevo 4 por 400 son
mixtos como lo decía juan jose sayago
que una de las noticias que
lamentablemente ha despertado o ha
bajado los ánimos en este mundial es la
información dada por luguelin santos el
medallista de plata de los juegos
olímpicos de londres y también de los
pasados en tokio de que no va a poder
estar presente de los anuncios a través
de sus redes sociales debido a el commit
que lo tiene que lo apartado de esta
competencia luguelin forma parte de un
relevo 4 por 400
importantísimo que ganó que fue
subcampeón pero regresamos con juan jose
para tratar de conseguir más información
si jose decíamos que es este relevo de 4
x 400 de república dominicana s
muy tiene muchas ambiciones en este
mundial
sin ambiciones estatales porque bien de
ser plata en los juegos olímpicos de
tokio y tienen amar y ley de paulino que
ha dominado todas las pruebas de 400 en
lo que va de temporada también los
velocistas dominicanas dominaron el
iberoamericano en todas las pruebas de
la velocidad y que bueno se van a perder
la posibilidad de estar con lo de linz
tanto como trataba de comentarlo al
principio en este post de instagram en
el que aseguraba pues ha dado positivo
en kobe 19 y no va a poder participar
quien fuera también medallista
individual en londres 2012 es decir que
la prueba de 400 la de varones no va a
tener ni a la medalla de oro ni a la
medalla de plata de todos que ni la
medalla de plata de londres-2012 ha sido
una prueba que ha sufrido bastante tanto
por las lesiones como ahora por el cob y
19 del resto esperemos entonces lo que
vamos a ceder al final de la tarde con
ese relevo 4 por 400 mixtos en el que
república dominicana seguramente va a
tratar de buscar lo que puede ser el
primer podio de este mundial que
comienza hoy a cae normal
bueno marquitas un pelín descafeinado
por el kobe 19 es algo que estamos
viendo en todos los deportes nos venimos
ahora hasta colombia con el fútbol
porque también tiene presencia y
france24 la copa américa de fútbol hoy
es día de acción en el grupo b2
goleadoras en cancha estefanía banini
por argentina a primera hora de haina
castellanos por venezuela a segunda
desde cali donde anoche tuvo jornada el
grupo a nuestra enviada especial
estefanía montero nos da un adelanto del
menú futbolístico de hoy
continúan las emociones en esta copa
américa femenina el día de ayer vivimos
una jornada vibrante una jornada llena
de emociones en el grupo 'a' y hoy en la
tercera fecha que viviremos del grupo
hoy tendremos a las protagonistas de
este grupo brasil la multicampeona y
favorita de este certamen descansará no
va a jugar la primera hora tendremos el
partido entre argentina y uruguay un
partido que promete muchas emociones un
partido que seguramente va a estar muy
cerrado unas uruguayas que defienden muy
bien y por supuesto una argentina que
viene con el rótulo de favorita por
haber estado en el mundial hace tres
años pero que quiere ratificar y quiere
seguir sumando quiere tener 6 puntos
para acomodarse en la tabla un uruguay
que por otro lado no ha sumado que ha
tenido dos derrotas pero que quiere
comenzar a sumar además porque su fútbol
así lo demuestra a segunda hora perú
versus venezuela las venezolanas vienen
de descansar y vienen además de haber
ganado en la primera jornada frente a
uruguay por supuesto querrán seguir en
la pelea imaginarán estar y seguir
sumando esos seis puntos que las
acomodarán muy bien en la tabla de
posiciones del grupo y como ves las
posibilidades para to be nestlé laumar
bueno
hoy pinta muy bien bueno me alegro
gracias por esta crónica deportiva y a
nuestros televidentes les invitamos a
que sigan conectados a france 24 y
france24 puntocom
[Música]